so Elon Musk is scheduled to take the
reins over at Twitter I believe on
Friday uh that's when the deal is
supposed to be official and he'll
actually be in charge of Twitter
um the left obviously is panicking over
it and and they're panicking because we
know they rely so much on on
suppressing speech and and and
that is all in service to kind of this
pretending that there are that there is
a consensus on an issue when there
really isn't as some people have called
it on Twitter you know
manufacturing a consensus
um that's the Great Value that uh that
Twitter has for the left and that all
social media doesn't have big Tech has
for them
is by pretending you know by by putting
their own views out there and pretend
and creating an environment where it
seems like everyone agrees with their
position when really they don't
um it's a
and that can be a very convincing thing
to people when they when we spend so
much time on social media and there's
one point of view that you see
everywhere you turn
and another point of view which might be
your own which you don't see represented
at all trick you into believing that uh
well you must be very much in the
minority and if you're in the minority
you must be wrong
but they manufacture this by suppressing
all other opinions
now they're afraid that's going to go
out the window
um so Elon Musk showed up to Twitter
headquarters yesterday uh it he posted a
quick video showing him carrying a sink
into the building here's that video
so I get it because they let that sink
in is it is it the pun
I think it's I'm always a fan of I'm
always an apologist for all forms of uh
dad jokes now we previously talked about
musk's reported plan to fire a huge
portion of the staff which is a great
idea it's even a better idea than the
pun and the pun was a fantastic idea
um and it's an even better idea in light
of this here's a video that Libs of tick
tock found and posted this is another
one of those Tick Tock videos where
somebody goes through their daily
routine I have no idea why this is a
trend
why these videos are so popular but they
are so here is the daily routine
of a Twitter employee watch
welcome to a day in my life as a Twitter
employee so this past week went to SF
for the first time at a Twitter office
badged in honestly took a moment to just
soak everything in what a blessing also
started my morning off with an iced
matcha from the perch then I had a
meeting so it's quickly scheduled one of
these little pod rooms which were so
cool they're literally noise canceling
took my meeting got ready for a bunch
look how delicious this food looks oh my
goodness I was so overwhelmed then made
my way down to this Log Cabin area I
don't know what this is but it was
really cool I played some foosball with
my friends to kind of unwind a bit
um also found this really cool
meditation room that I thought was super
neat
um I didn't do any yoga but they have
this yoga room if you are a yogi so I
also thought that was really cool
um had a couple more meetings in the
afternoon had a ton of projects that we
needed to knock out say hi to my
teammates
um went to the went to the library to
kind of get some more work done
obviously had to have our afternoon
coffee so made some espresso and then
before leaving for the day I had some
red wine
um that's on tap went up to the rooftop
and just honestly enjoyed the beautiful
weather so awesome trip
that no work but it was done at all well
she had a meeting so we had a meeting
for 15 minutes
I think there's a lot of fat we can trim
here I really think that there is so he
wants to fire 75 employees I think he
probably fired 90 and we would be fine
uh I love how she says that she had to
unwind by playing some foosball with her
friends
unwind you just you just got you got to
work an hour ago
you spent most of the time drinking
coffee and hanging out and meditating
and you already have to unwind
if you have time for yoga and foosball
and meditation during the work day you
aren't needed okay good rule of thumb
there if I was an employer I I might put
all of that stuff in the office just so
that I can fire whoever uses it
it gives people an opportunity to sort
of tell on themselves I think it's
actually a brilliant idea the more that
I think about this
it's really not a bad idea have a have a
swimming pool have a hot tub have a
water park uh have lounge chairs and
reading material and
you know all that kind of stuff
have a room that says like the it's the
uh it's the the Netflix room you just
sit there and browse Netflix and watch
Netflix movies
and anyone caught using any of that is
fired automatically
I'm half joking well I'm not really
joking at all I would do that but the
point is that if you don't want to be
fired if you want to have job security
and this is not just a lesson for
Twitter employees it's for everybody you
have to make yourself Irreplaceable as
Irreplaceable as possible I mean the
reality is that nobody is totally
Irreplaceable but your value to your
employer increases with the degree of
your ear replaceability okay
um if they can find
just anyone off the street to do your
job then you have almost no value
as an employee
sadly
it's just that's the reality of it it's
not very might not be nice to think
about but it is
if they can find anyone else if they
pull anybody else in and have them do it
then you don't you just don't have a lot
of value
now if they would have extreme
difficulty finding someone who can bring
what you bring to the table then you
have immense value
which means you have bargaining power
and you have leverage
speaking of which I just saw the uh so
Starbucks has a a union now the
Starbucks employees have unionized
and uh they were complaining earlier
this week because they were they were
trying to have a meeting with uh with
twit with a Starbucks management you
know Starbucks corporate management and
the corporate walked out of the meeting
they complained and they said they just
got up and walked out they wouldn't they
wouldn't negotiate
well this again goes back to you have to
have leverage you have to have
bargaining power
and if you work at Starbucks for example
like there's there are a lot of people
who can do that and so you just don't
have a lot of Leverage
Twitter employees especially don't
understand this understand this
um
and what they think is they can just
make demands so this is from time
okay Time Magazine has this employees at
Twitter are circulating an open letter
protesting Elon musk's plan to fire as
much as 75 percent of the companies
Workforce as the deadline for him to
complete his 44 billion dollar
acquisition of the company looms time
has learned
musk must complete the acquisition by
Friday or face the resumption of a
lawsuit in Delaware Court
um and uh the plan is that he will
eradicate the jobs of nearly 75 percent
of Twitter staff reducing headcount from
7 500 to Just 2 000.
according to Washington Post now here's
the letter that they're circulating it
says
staff Elon Musk and board of directors
we the underside Twitter workers believe
the public conversation is in jeopardy
Elon musk's plan it's the public
conversation is in jeopardy
because it's not going to be suppressed
anymore
the public conversation is in Jeopardy
when more people are allowed to
participate in it
it's very similar to how we're going to
face the end of democracy if too many
Republicans participate in it and vote
for Republicans that's the end of
democracy
so it's the end of the public
conversation if there are too many
people involved in the conversation
Elon musk's plan to lay off 75 of
Twitter workers will hurt Twitter's
ability to serve the public conversation
a threat of this magnitude is reckless
undermines our users and customers trust
in our platform and is a transparent Act
of worker intimidation
Twitter has significant effects on
societies and communities across the
globe as we speak Twitter is helping to
uplift independent journalism in Ukraine
and Iran as well as powering social
movements around the world a threat to
workers at Twitter is a threat to
Twitter's Future these threats have an
impact on us as workers and demonstrate
a fundamental disconnect with the
realities of operating Twitter they
threaten our livelihoods access to
essential Healthcare and the ability for
Visa holders to stay in the country they
work in we cannot do our work in an
environment of constant harassment and
threats without our work there is no
Twitter well yeah but we're which is
the point is that many of you don't need
to do your work anymore because you're
going to be fired so I don't even
understand if you fire us we will not be
able to do our work at Twitter well yeah
that's the whole point we don't you're
not needed
we the workers at Twitter will not be
intimidated we recommit to supporting
the communities organizations and
businesses who rely on Twitter we will
not stop serving the public conversation
well you will if you get fired
then you will
that's how it works we call on Twitter
management and Elon Musk to cease these
negligent layoff threats as workers we
deserve concrete commitment so we can
continue to preserve the Integrity of
our platform we demand of current and
future leadership respect we demand a
leadership to respect the platform and
the workers who maintain it by
committing to preserving the current
head count
safety we demand that leadership does
not discriminate against workers on the
basis of their race gender disability
sexual orientation or political beliefs
oh now they're worried about people
being discriminated against based on
based on political beliefs we also
demand safety for workers on visas we
will be forced to leave the country or
who will be first to leave the country
if they work
um they're working if they're laid off
protection we demand Elon Musk
explicitly commit to preserve our
benefits those both listed in the merger
agreement and not we demand leadership
to establish and ensure Fair Severance
policies for all workers before and
after any change in ownership we demand
transparent prompt and thoughtful
communication around our working
conditions we demand to be treated with
dignity and to not be treated as mere
Pawns in a game played by billionaires
okay again these demands mean nothing if
you have no Leverage
and notice how they they never even
try to pretend that they have leverage
they didn't say
here's what we bring to the company okay
here's what we do every day
um and and you need us to do this and
here's what will happen if you get rid
of us hear all the bad things will
happen to the company
um into the company's bottom line
without us
okay here's what will happen if you
don't have us doing yoga and eating
hummus all day this these are this is
this is the catastrophe that we'll do
they didn't really do that instead they
just went right to playing the victim
card emotional blackmail
if you fire us
it'll make us feel bad
that's their argument
you know it's just it probably won't
work if you get called into the office
and the boss lets you know listen it's
not working out we got to go our
separate ways you can't do that why
can't I do it
because I don't like it
it makes me it makes me feel bad to be
fired
okay well
sorry to hear that
anyway here's your box fill it with
stuff and get the hell out please
um
just that you can you can make demands
all you want but the demand doesn't mean
anything if you have no Leverage
and leverage as an employer is tied to
what you actually do to how you perform
to what you bring to the table
the problem is that a lot of these
people have been told that it doesn't
matter what they do it doesn't matter
what they bring to the table they
shouldn't have to prove themselves to
anyone
and they should be allowed to continue
working at Twitter just because because
it's it's they they are them and they
are special
just doesn't work that way unfortunately
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not
talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]